back on should President Obama send arms
to Ukraine or is this a European problem
that we should stay out of yes it is
next question
Marianne you you ran as an independent
last fall what are the limits of our
current two-party system well I think
that Wow
you know George Washington first of all
his farewell address warned us against
parties period and in the history of
social justice particularly in real
change in the United States third party
voices have been extremely important
abolition movement came out of the
abolitionist party women's suffrage came
out of the women's suffrage always
absorbing one of the tonight but it's
important that you have that third yeah
and so there is really kind of
conspiracy that's lasted for a few
decades now to to marginalize and make
very very difficult to be heard third
party voices and I think it's to the
detriment of our political dialogue okay
Amy what's your opinion on Fox News and
others choosing to post on their website
the recent Isis video I'm very
conflicted about that I think it's
disrespectful to the pilot and to his
family
yet on the other hand to see the reality
of what Isis is capable of personally I
would not be able to watch the video
I've you know seen the links to
beheading videos that one I clicked and
I started to hear the gurgling had to
shut it off I just cannot have those
images in my mind we should also be
showing the atrocities that commit by my
government in your government we should
and by the Saudi regime which we support
arm and fund every day speaking of all
the horror that we have these beheadings
this is what war is
I wish we had felt more of this horror
in a more sober thinking about whether
or not to even go into a war these
atrocities happen every day and some of
them happen from well I made punished
our war crimes we there's nothing really
compare well the kind Henry Kissinger is
a lauded a revered person on one of the
worst criminals in the United States you
don't punish your war criminals I'm
afraid but well the most beautiful war
he's awesome he didn't
didn't go out in ten cherries well you
want to talk to the people of Chile
about that but the and you know I
interviewed against what you said
because I interviewed a lot of former
jihadis in Britain who become jihadists
and it stopped him it's very interesting
overwhelmingly they became jihad ease
when our governments were committing
atrocities against their people and they
stopped because ordinary Western people
were decent and kind to them and they
thought I can't support tacking these
people the more aggressive we are
there's some jihadism you're totally
right that is just spontaneous vile
religious mania right that's real that
exists the more aggressive and abusive
we are in response the more that grows
the more we show ourselves to be good
and loving and decent people the more it
diminishes we've got to look at the
evidence
um yes what do you how do you feel about
watching that video I don't listen to
the guests I'm sorry yeah no I mean I
don't think we I don't think we needed I
I think we get it about Isis I don't I
don't I think that's not true
um I do I mean it's obvious that America
has also burned people alive from the
air I mean in World War two but you know
I mean World War II World War Two was it
I don't know just well wilty the drone
attacks in Pakistan are incinerating
children upon all the time you know
compris I'm gonna target here's a little
more liquidities a little bit mean you
know yeah okay collateral damage is
alerting him to death that's right the
collateral damage using different that's
the line that separates this arc you
know Jeremy stay home on your own the
guests right documented that's pretty
atrocious in that America is certainly
not guilt-free but I don't think we're
the moral equivalent of Isis no I don't
know about their crimes many like you
say finest minute of war but we don't go
to our to our utmost to try and minimize
as agile T's that's why I mean there
have been American well not only not and
the rules of engagement were written
such way that there are working men who
are dead today because they file I mean
we said protect civilian life at the end
of World War two before we drop the atom
bomb we wiped out from 50 to 90 percent
of the population of Japan's biggest 60
cities that's some serious [ __ ] sure for
you don't need to go so far back they'll
you know sanctions against Iraq even
forget Bush's war sanctions against Iraq
half a million children died as a result
of those sections do you blockade
medicines from going into a country huge
numbers of people die that's very recent
these people were talking about Isis who
are disgusting and barbaric they
remember that if you want to know why
these people are attacking them some of
its spontaneous religious bigotry all
right something is responding to
atrocities maybe don't be poor in that
question here we're not in the
International Criminal Court okay
what do you think of Pete Carroll's play
call at the end of the Super Bowl
something that matters oh you know what
over to you on be very confident
controversial right here I think a pass
play was the right call but not that
pass play
if you pass at that point you stop the
clock no seriously look at this look at
the play if if he if he had run the ball
Marshawn Lynch got stuff four to five
times on the one-yard line and I see it
and if you run the ball you get stuff
you burn your last time out you don't
have time worth about this run I know I
remember what watching the game it at
the end of the first half they were
there was like a few seconds left and
they had an automatic field goal and
they chose to go for the touchdown and
as they were doing that everybody if my
party was like this is a stupid call
what an idiot what an it what a genius
and I just I mean that pass it was six
inches and it would have been a
completion the guy made a great play
it's a chess game they were all stacked
up so he went for this thing this is
what these people do 24/7 I just want to
know all these people who say it's the
worst call ever if it had worked which
it could have what they have said you
know it worked but it's still the worst
call left I say it so no a 1 in 400
chance of that ball is intercepted and
it was intercepted yeah even that play
was and what an amazing finish that game
right ok um Janet assuming that the
Supreme Court rules in favor of the
right to marry are you concerned that
all other LGBT issues will then fall
from America's consciousness no I think
that it's been the flagship issue for
the LGBT community but it only helps
just a portion of the LGBT community I'm
looking forward to the day when all
different kinds of families are
recognized of course but I I think that
there's other dire daily access issues
specifically if you talk about trans
people the violence that trans women
specifically trans women of color face I
know just in LA alone in the past three
months three months there's been four
murders of black trans women and I think
that that's something that there is a
lot of violence right oh there there's
tons of violence I think so much of it
is is linked to the idea that women are
not valued people of color are not
valued and trans people are often
invalidated within our society and so
when you throw that all into one
person's body there's a lot of targeting
that comes in that space and so I think
that we need to have a national outrage
over these bodies that are often no
one's really protecting and I caught it
when there maybe I'm wrong but I thought
the violence came from because
the transgender person didn't tell the
guy about IDs and then the guy kissed
her or something and then daddy was like
oh now I'm a homo no no a lot of it a
lot of it is just based on street
harassment if you're walking down the
street as a trans woman and in a guy cat
calls you and that level of violence at
any woman kind of deals with on the
street just through verbal violence it
escalates when you discover that you're
trans men didn't get upset this happened
just through someone could just look you
know I don't know how people read people
when how they discover that someone's
trans but this happened in Harlem just
Rams doorless maybe there's some kind of
maybe there's some kind of some kind of
essence that one gives off but I don't
really know how to unpack how cisgender
people tend to look at trans people but
I know that in Harlem last year I could
never tell looking at you
well yeah well I bet you that's a label
thank you but that's that's a level of
that well you know thank you that it's
example of it well that's something
that's kinda it enables me and to go
into spaces without having to be checked
without having to deal with violence and
harassment but that's not the reality
for a lot of trans people and you
shouldn't have to look like me in order
to have a level of safety in our in our
culture but if you were if you were
dating someone say I mean would you tell
them right away well I've been dating
people since I was 16 years old I'm
engaged now I put a ring on it but um
but you both are oh yeah I am I know
these modern tricks but I think it just
matters on the into the level of
intimacy in the relationship if someone
is gonna have coffee with no I'm not
like what Janice but you know maybe if
we're about your famous but I mean if
you were yeah now it's completely out of
the bag I said I'm good do the
Republicans have any real plan to
replace Obamacare and what would that
look like you know I'm the guy who
founded the war on drugs once said I've
made up my mind don't try to confuse me
with the facts and I kind of think that
should be not only the logo for this the
war on drugs but basically the broader
Republican approach to almost all health
issues
there's one by Tom Coburn Richard burr
I'd said it there there in more well
form than Democratic plans were before
they took the White House so I think and
what is that what is the essence of them
it's neither subsidies but they're less
generous or if you were mandates to make
it cost less I don't know but without
mandates you really can't get I mean you
I mean I think I mean the real problem
that AMA care is that all the employer
all the mandates that are requiring
every certain thing to be covered I
think that once you at when you can't
have a stripped-down plan like an HSA it
just makes it cost that much more the
real problem is this is the richest
country in the world and it's the only
country in the developed world it
doesn't provide health care for all of
its citizens
that's a disgrace Americans deserve
better
no sir than we used to be the question
becomes not just what are the
Republicans going to do but what are the
Democrats going to do they wouldn't
allow public option we need to have the
conversation about single-payer we need
to have spine around that conversation
and to know that if we're government of
the people by the people for the people
primary there should be universal health
care thank you